[Music]
I was in a lift ironically because uber
shut me out because they complained
about sexual harassment before any of us
came out I was like your driver just had
something really creepy and they froze
my account was an asset Oh 13 so I was
in a lift and it was about five days
after the big New York Times Harvey
Weinstein story broke and this is a
metaphor this is to help people
understand what a victim of abuse goes
through first so you have to understand
like let's say there's a gazelle ur &
ibex and they're chased by a lion and
they get away or they get nailed do you
think it's the first time they've been
chased by a lion this happens a lot this
guy the driver he couldn't see me I was
behind him and I use a different name
I'm there and he was listening to news
radio and it started talking about this
and he said out loud I don't understand
why those women couldn't have just
bought him off
and I said sir her I'm a disembodied
voice to him I said have you ever been
so scared that you froze like a statue
he stopped actually stop the car he
pulled over and he didn't still get like
I mean he went almost into this trance
II kind of state yes I was 10 I was
scared so badly my feet or clay I
couldn't move I've never felt anything
like is that what it's like is that what
happens to you yes but it doesn't have
to happen
that's so point of what I do to stop
hurting us you know it's like when I
meet people and they're like oh I'm not
on the creative side no wave their hands
at me as if it's the disease and I think
how old are you and I took that from me
how old were you and they told you is a
lie that you were one thing and it
belongs to a business card that's you
that's your identity people keep
referring to me as actress my haven't
done that in a long time I have no
intention of ever doing it again that
was also you know I worked at a funeral
home that's also not how I get
introduced right I've done a lot of
other things Allah I do many other
things but it's just a classification
system as some some of you know the word
actress is very loaded like celebrity
like liberal like moral right all these
things have negative kind of feminism
but if you look at these words and if
you look at the definitions are
beautiful moral the definition is
gorgeous how dare we let these people
steal it people think you know the New
York Times reviewed my book and people
like what a great review and I was
annoyed by it I thought that was stupid
this person with her khaki pants brain
is not understanding my point how
annoying the last sentence was oh this
should be great for teenage girls fuck
you I cut that I'm sure no it's not
great for teenage girls it will be as an
addendum
I want the 50 year old I'm at the six
year old I want the man I want the woman
I want the 8 year old I want anybody
because those are the ones messing those
young people up and that is how we have
a cycle The Kids Are Alright it's all
y'all that's who I'm talking to
I wish needs have a conversation I
really just wanted to have a Gertrude
Stein esque conversation with the world
but not having only be snooty people
it's not that complicated
[Music]